[Music]
chris sims the popular co-host a pro
football talk live that uh precedes our
show on peacock also seem on uh football
night in america what is going on with
the cleveland browns and baker mayfield
here
yeah well i mean you know i i think one
thing that i talk about on my podcast or
the show with florio a lot that just
jumps out to me after studying them you
know the first thing is
it's we said this a little a few weeks
ago i believe when i was on with you you
know the it's a run game offense they
want to run the ball that's what they do
best when the pass game has to stand
stand alone by itself uh they struggle
you know it's you know a little bit
because of baker mayfield certainly
hasn't been the best at reading the
field been a little off target yes the
schemes themselves are a little
underwhelming where you go just you know
okay it's good but it's not anything
real creative so that's what i look at
let alone he's beat up to go along with
that and i think that's where you know
the the problem lies in my opinion you
know more than anything it's just very
run game centric and it's all dependent
on nick chubb and what they do there
yeah but they rush for 200 yards against
detroit baker threw two picks they
scored 13 points yeah well at some point
you need to be able to
go exactly it's got to go back to him
making a few throws you know i chat you
know go back watch the game you know if
the two interceptions are egregiously
bad you know and then you know out of
the i think he was what 15 for 29 or
somewhere in that ballpark as far as the
stats are concerned there's five or six
throws in the game where you go
whoa whoa whoa he missed that badly you
know for a 15 20 25 yard gain that of
course we know changes field position
maybe gets you another field goal puts
more pressure on detroit those are the
things that start to you know funnel
towards a blowout or a dominant win and
when you don't take advantage of those
opportunities you let a lesser team hang
around and
that's exactly kind of what happened we
spent a little bit of time uh starting
the show talking about the giants that
they have no identity here
daniel jones to me doesn't feel like a
starting quarterback he's got a lot of
athletic ability but he makes bad
decisions saquon barkley you're not
going to sign him up to a second
contract
i got a gm who's probably in limbo here
a coach who's trying to channel bill
belichick without having tom brady
what
where did the giants go from here
yeah they got a lot of issues i mean you
you said it you know i mean
i'm a little bit of a defender of joe
judge i am you know first off like i
don't have the same feeling i did with
pat shermer or ben mcadoo where i saw
one year and i was like whoa that
they're they're in over their heads see
ya later let's go to the next guy you
know i don't this one i look at a little
bit differently to where hey they i
think exceeded expectations a little bit
last year with how they played this year
yeah it's been a little underwhelming
but i also sit there and just go you
know it's hard to win football games in
the nfl when you have maybe the worst
offensive line in football you know
that's the first thing i would say
there's problems throughout their roster
no great pass rusher no no athletic
middle linebackers that can you know
that translate to the modern day nfl as
far as like staying on the field
covering running backs covering tight
ends they don't have that you know they
overpaid guys like james bradbury at
corner they pay him like he's a shut
down stefan gillard gilmore jaylen
ramsey jayal alexander type that's not
true you know that hasn't happened you
know so i think there's just a lot of
things i look at throughout the roster
where i just go
yeah it doesn't give them a fighting
chance on a week-to-week basis let alone
you're right saquon his injury history
daniel jones hasn't played his best
played paid kenny gallaudet like he's
supposed to be like one of the best
receivers in football they overpaid for
that that didn't work you know
trade odell beckham jr get your jabril
peppers okay that's okay nothing special
there they traded away the i mean they
cut zeitler or traded them to the ravens
in the off season so i just look at the
roster as being the number one issue
with the giants let alone some other
things sprinkled in to go along with it
but you have these standalone games and
after a standalone games that means
everybody there it's fully full exposure
everybody's got an opinion on tom brady
and the buccaneers everybody's got an
opinion on the giants as well are the
buccaneers the best team in the nfc
oh um i think when they're gonna be at
full health
you know and they're getting close to
that i i have a hard time arguing that i
i do you know i think it shawn murphy
bunting being back last night if they
get carlton davis back in a few weeks i
believe that's going to help veda veya
hey they dodged a bullet by him not
being out for the year you know we see
the gronk effect when he gets back in
the lineup he's such an issue to deal
with because he's like having an extra
tackle in the run game let alone we know
he's awesome in the past game to go
along with that so
yes i think when the bucks are healthy
and all the stars aligned they're the
most dangerous complete football team in
the nfc there's no doubt about that
let's go through the
awkward quarterbacking situations and
yeah and awkward doesn't mean it's bad
new york is bad but what we have like
san francisco that's an awkward
situation because jimmy g is a better
quarterback than trey lance right now
but trey lance is their future
how does that how do they solve that
they're they're gonna i mean they're
gonna have to see how the rest of this
year plays out and i think that's the
first thing and then as they're doing
that evaluate trey lance and his
progress and see where he's at with this
whole situation as well he's raw as we
as we've seen we knew that coming out
you know in the draft we saw it in the
arizona game where he got to play a few
weeks ago you know there's some wow
plays but the ball it sprays all over
the place at times he doesn't know how
to take care of himself he's running
around like his north dakota state there
you know that one to me still has the
chance to be very dicey dan it really
does because i think the 49ers gonna end
up being a player here in the nfc i do
now that they're healthy shanahan seems
got his groove back a little bit
kittle's back the way they're using
deebo samuel they've gotten brandon iuke
out of the funk you know the defenses is
i'm not gonna say like the super bowl
gear defense but still good a top 10
defense in football and yeah i do wonder
because i expect them to make the
playoffs and they get in the playoffs in
the nfc it's crazy yeah i think there is
just about as good as anybody there
other than maybe the bucks so where i
look at that and go man that shanahan
you know good thing he's getting paid a
lot of money because he's going to have
some tough things to deal with in the
off season okay some of the other
awkward quarterbacking situations i'm
going to throw the dolphins in there
right i think the saints is an awkward
it feels like they have three
quarterbacks but they don't have one
quarterback the panthers you know cam
nice reunion tour you're paying sam
darnold next year
the seahawks if they don't make the
playoffs and russell wilson does he want
to stay does pete carroll want to stay
or whatever happens there the steelers
with ben
could he play just good enough to go hey
i think i'll come back for another year
and then you got the cleveland browns so
out of all of those
what what's one is more interesting to
you
oh they're all good i think steelers and
big ben this will be it period i think
they're going to be a player their
team's ready to win now i think there'll
be a player for one of the
watson rogers russell wilson whoever
comes available that's the way i'm going
to throw that out there seattle is the
most interesting a little bit just
because of the whole situation you know
yeah i you know from the things i know
about russell wilson things he said to
people i know that i trust in the nfl in
the offseason yeah i think a lot of
signs point towards him like saying see
you later seattle i'm out of here after
this year and i wonder just what happens
in seattle all together i mean of course
it's been a great run but they're
borderline like
we might have to blow up the team here
you know that's they've been putting
band-aids on things for the last few
years you know nothing great on the
offensive line you know running backs
okay solid you got two receivers no
great defensive lineman nobody that
jumps out you know jamal adams hasn't
worked out to the capacity i think they
wanted to and they got no good cover
corners there's a lot of issues there so
i think i look at seattle maybe
and
probably the miami situation as being
the one that i look at to be the most
interesting like cleveland with baker
mayfield dan you know they got a little
leeway here i mean i think we said this
a few weeks ago first off why would you
overpay him
what has he done right now to say oh we
got to get the contract done no one's
going to be beaten down the door for
baker mayfield and free agency and you
got the fifth year option you know as
far as that flexibility is concerned as
well so i think he's there at least for
now
but that miami seattle situation very
interesting we're talking to chris sims
pro football talk live co-host you can
also see him on football night in
america
i'm curious if jonathan taylor can do
enough
to sneak in and win an mvp because it
feels like we don't have a legitimate
front-runner for the mvp
yeah what would jonathan taylor have to
do
to win the mvp uh i think that
you know obviously lead the league in
rushing and have a a number that like
wows you i think that's the first thing
like you know not that it has to be 2
000 but if he gets up there to that 17
1800 mark you know gets to
like right now i think he's at what 13
touchdowns maybe even more adding the
run game i'm trying to look at my stats
stats here as i'm talking to you like
he's got to get somewhere in the 20 the
20 area he's on pace for 20 and he's on
pace for a little over 1600 yards yeah
is that enough if they
yeah he needs a little more to me like
he needs to be 18. he needs another 200
yard rushing game to be thrown in there
and another three or four touchdown
performance along with them making the
playoffs
and him obviously being the marquee
player there and i think also to say
it's enough he needs
maybe one of the few of these
quarterbacks again to kind of just fall
on their face a little bit a little bit
here and there and you know he needs to
hope brady throws another few
interceptions and stafford continues to
stumble uh then he can do it but it is a
very odd year and uh very wide open from
that
that standpoint i mean the the nfl is
crazy this year it's crazy as i can ever
remember
but i don't know who the leading
candidate is you know i thought if dak
had a big game in kansas city then he
might rise above aaron rodgers was great
but they lost that game
um i'm going to hold it against him that
he missed the kansas city game
uh
you know josh allen has not played well
brady's been up and down back-to-back
losses
uh tyler murray's been out
so i know
i know it it's crazy it is you know i
look at like
um
one guy i mean you know it's gonna end
up being a quarterback i think if you
made me bet right now the way it is and
the way the team looks it's gonna end up
being brady that's the way i look at it
you know especially if they get antonio
brown back you know i just think they
got too many weapons and as long as they
can protect him just like we saw last
night he just can dice you up as as good
as anybody in the game they got a good
system they're creative he's got
mismatches everywhere that'd be the guy
i'd probably say right now but you know
i am i'm rooting for like jonathan
taylor a little bit to make this
interesting no doubt about it another
guy that i think is like
no not a quarterback but needs to be
quietly in this discussion as well
if you want to just say what mvp means
to me would be deebo samuel with the
49ers
that's another guy i know it's like but
man he leads the lead leads the team in
receiving he's one of the best receivers
in football and now i got him playing
damn tailback too he's the best hail
back on the team you know he is the mvp
of their team for sure and if they
continue to make some crazy rise and he
continues to have these crazy stat lines
i'll throw him out there but i'm gonna
give brady the edge right now the
mannings last night talked about you
don't blitz brady i mean that's not you
know
that enlightening because kurt warner
has talked about that too he wanted you
to blitz
but teams still blitz you know brady
gets the
rid of the ball so quick why why do
teams blitz uh some of these
quarterbacks who are more in the pocket
stationary quarterbacks
yeah well you know you got to be careful
and brady's one you got to be careful
about blitzing you know certainly you
know he knows where to go with the
football he's you know he's been in two
you know offensive systems that have
answers for the blitzes too you know
some of these quarterbacks don't have
answers they're just like hey there's
blitz just throw it real quick to the
hot route guy right there and it's like
well yeah the other team knows they're
going to throw it too quick to the hot
rod guy too it's not always open you
know you got to have protection answers
you know other rules within the
protections and routes that kind of
combat those issues but yeah brady's
going to dice up the blitz if you're too
obviously it just has to be a smattering
of blitzes and to me it's the illusion
of pressure and blitz that gets pretty
like if you watch the washington and the
saints game a little bit dan you know
and i know you did i'm not trying to say
you didn't but they it's a lot of wait
you know two guys blitz over here but
two guys drop out over here so now it's
a little like wait am i protected did i
get guys in the right place wait now i
gotta get my eyes downfield what the
hell coverage are they playing that to
me is what you do to brady unlike what
the giants did last night who have no
pass rusher and then played very vanilla
on the back end you know to where he
could just dice them up but yeah you got
to have a special front four and i think
the illusion of complexity and pressure
just to fluster him a little bit i just
don't see a reason why brady is going to
retire anytime soon no way i'm with you
why would you leave that team i mean yes
he's still throwing lasers all over the
football field and he knows how to
protect himself and he's got a team
that's they're set up to dominate the
nfc at least for the next two or three
years so i'm with you enjoy the tampa
sun enjoy the house that chris sims
built for him and just kind of go from
there
uh
all the great memories of you in tampa
bay
oh yeah of all the great memories yeah
that's right it was a great time it's a
great football town you know they might
not have like the wealth to always have
you know season tickets sold out all the
time and everything like that but man do
they love football you know it's
borderline sec country up there in tampa
as you get to northern florida and they
love their bucks so i'm happy to see
those fans getting to enjoy this for
sure great to talk to you happy
thanksgiving and uh
tell your dad smack your dad right in
the shoulder or something like oh
definitely i'll take it farther than the
shoulder the back of the head or the
chest or something and you make sure you
return that favor to the rest of those
idiots there too whoa
yeah that's right i said it boom eat it
see you guys happy thanksgiving to all
of you thank you chris that's chris sims
he was being serious with that
pro football talk live i don't know if
he could take his dad
his dad's still tough
man i he he had old man strength even
when he was younger when i would cover
the giants and it's like phil sims man
they threw him around like a ragdoll
tough guy
tough guy